I used to be just like you vulnerable
uncertain frightened of death
12 hours ago I Mike's is like saying to
the driver do you want to write a
Ferrari
I want to be sure that i'm using it the
right place the right moment Lucy is
everyone she's a 25 years old student
she's in Taipei she's wondering what
she's gonna do with her life she's a
little lost in fact and falling or her
lap this situation where she will be
able to reach the father part of her
brain it is said that we humans only use
ten percent of our cerebral capacity but
what if there was a way of accessing one
hundred percent of our brain it's an
amazing journey for this girl and for us
too because we like her good good
happens to me or you time to go then we
have worked in imax and you can really
feel the difference at the end mitt
don't move she has abilities but
especially the last 15 minutes of the
films where you really go out of space
and that was very useful to me people
who will have the chance to see non-imax
we have a full experience of the film
and it will probably be even more in
shock at the end
you